صفقة الاختطاف
ستدفع Anho بنفسها الثمن بلا شك من أجل الوصول
لصفقة جيدة من الصعب أن نقول ما هو عليه
صفقة جيدة وصحيحة لأنه، كما ذكرنا، أيدينا عالية جدًا
لذلك كان القاع في Shav 1 في أكتوبر
وعلينا أن نتغلب على هذه الصعوبة الآن
السفينة التي فعلت الشيء الصحيح يجب أن تكون سعيدة
من قبل حكومة الحرب، وربما الحكومة الإسرائيلية بأكملها
أولئك الذين يجب عليهم الموافقة عليه لديهم أسعار صعبة
كثيرًا بالنسبة لدولة إسرائيل، ليس هناك شك في ما نحن عليه
ويبدو أن وقف إطلاق النار هو الثمن الذي يتعين على إسرائيل أن تدفعه
أريد أن أطلب منك كسر شيء معك
سأقولها شيئًا واحدًا في كل مرة، فلنبدأ من البداية
أعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون هناك إيقاع واحد فقط فيه
تم إطلاق سراح جميع المختطفين ولم يتم إطلاق سراح المختطفين
كما لم يتم عقد اجتماع متابعة لمجلس الوزراء
لا تنقل أي رسالة إلى الوسطاء القطريين والمصريين
إسرائيل تلتزم الصمت لتعطي حماس
للتردد والعودة بالإجابة النهائية ولكن الآن
رجال نتنياهو يبذلون كل ما في وسعهم أمام بن
جابر وساموترتز الضلعان غير المستقرين
الحكومة للتأكد من بقائهم فيها أيضًا
صفقة الظل للتجربة العملية هي أن نفهم منهم ماذا
إنهم ذوو الكعب الأحمر الحقيقي بسبب شعبي
نتنياهو لا يهتم حقاً إذا بنى وير وسموتريتش
سوف يصوتون ضد الصفقة، لا يهم أن نتنياهو فعل ذلك
معظم ما يهتمون به هو ما إذا كان جارهم هو سموتريتز
سوف يتقاعد من الحكومة، فهو طريق مسدود أو هو عليه
ببساطة في موقف محبط حيث نواجه شخصًا فارغًا
عواطف خالية من القيم مجردة من الإنسانية التي يصعب الوصول إليها
معه إلى الاتفاقيات التي نتحدث عنها الآن
سنوار قلبي بن نتنياهو لم أتحدث عنه
سينو أوه لم أفهم بشكل لا لبس فيه الجواب
أنه منذ بيبي نتنياهو يجيب أيضا على الجميع
هذه التعاريف يا رئيس الوزراء الجواب
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله هو أنه بالتأكيد ليس كذلك
الوضع المحبط فقط هو الركود، إنه الإهمال والرأس
ومن المؤكد أن حكومتي مسؤولة شخصيا عن ذلك
لكن شينوار، الذي يمثل مشكلة كبيرة، يمثل عقبة
فهو ليس العائق الوحيد، بل هو العائق الوحيد
أنه لا توجد سياسة لنا كدولة ذات سيادة في بلدها
مذهل وهذا ما عينته حكومتي لمجلس الوزراء
شيلي ورئيس الوزراء شيلي موريا سيف والبيرج تام
المنشور الأول عن محاولات الحد من
التوترات بين إسرائيل
بالنسبة لمصر، نعم، التوتر مع مصر موجود
وبيسيا نعلن الليلة ولأول مرة أن إسرائيل
دراسة مع مصر إمكانية نقل المعبر
السخام إلى المثلث الحدودي إسرائيل عنزة مصر
بالنسبة لمنطقة كريم شالوم فإن الهدف هو السماح من ناحية
تورط المصريين في الفترة الانتقالية بعدم دخول إيمو معهم
حول هذه القضية وعلى الجانب الآخر للتأكد من أن المرحلة الانتقالية
وسيكون أيضًا على الحدود مع إسرائيل وسيسمح بفحص أزرق
سيسمح وايت فعليًا لإسرائيل بالوصول للتحقق من ذلك
وقد شرعت إسرائيل في منع التهريب عبر هذا الطريق
هذا الموضوع في الأيام الأخيرة أيضا قبل المضيق
حتى أنهم ردوا بالإيجاب، ولكن أيضًا أمام الأمريكيين
لقد أعجبتهم هذه الفكرة وإذا نجحت
سيتعين على الممارس أيضًا الاستثمار ماليًا خلال ذلك
وبالطبع نومر لا يحل مشكلة التهريب
بشكل عام والخطاب متوتر نوعا ما بين إسرائيل
ومصر حول محور فيلادلفيا سوف تستمر أيضا
وفي المستقبل القريب سيرحل رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
بشكل عام، على مخطط ضخم ليس مجرد صفقة، بل هو أيضا
المسلسل في غزة ومع التطبيع السعودي إذا
ويرتبط هذا الحدث بالموافقة على الدولة الفلسطينية
وهذا جنون بالنسبة لدولة إسرائيل
أنا أعارضه، وأعتقد أنه حبة سم لا ينبغي السماح بها
أعتقد أن قبول إسرائيل بذلك يقوض الجميع
ما نقاتل من أجله هو ما نحن من أجله
نحن نتحدث عن اليوم التالي للسيطرة الأمنية الإسرائيلية
في قطاع غزة، كما في يهودا والسامرة، ليس الأمر مدنيا
الأمان كيف يمكنك التحكم في الأمان
في أراضي بلد آخر إذا كنا نتحدث عن بلد ما
الفلسطيني بعد الشفاء في أكتوبر يشبه الحديث
بعد الأول من سبتمبر المدينة المنورة لال كيدا المدينة المنورة
الفلسطيني ليس فقط ما لا نحتاجه
للحصول عليها نحن بحاجة للذهاب في حملة إعلامية
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وهو ما يفسر سبب إنشاء قاعدة إرهابية في قلب أرض إسرائيل
الأمر الذي من شأنه أن يقوض كل الاستقرار
لقد تم إنقاذ الشخص الإقليمي الذي هرب من زيكي هنا
واضح تماما
وهو نوع من القائد الهادئ الذي يتفق مع شيء واحد
عمليات البحث في عمليات البحث المفاجئة وجدت هذا الكتاب
في حوزة أخيها
سنوار هذا كتاب مكتوب بخط اليد تمت ترجمته بواسطة هالاخا
في الواقع كتابان لرؤساء منظمات الشباك
في الماضي، كان هناك أمر بحجم 500600 صفحة
إنه في الواقع يريد أن يترجم للأثرياء الأمنيين
ما رأي الآخرين في إلههم الروحي في شيك؟
وهو يترجم أيضًا للآخرين، لكنه يدرس نفسه ويقرأ
استراتيجية
إن منتقي رقعة الشطرنج يعرفون العدو بشكل كامل
ما هي الكتب التي ترجمها كتاب واحد لجاكوب بيري
القادم إلى موتك والكتاب الثاني شبيك بن كريم للكاتب أ
من ورقة الماء البارد
نعم، الانشقاق بين قراء كير ماجلون يتناول الكثير
في الصدع في المجتمع الإسرائيلي، هذا ما أراده
لدراسته والبحث فيه وهذا ما عمل عليه
أكمل قراءة المجتمع الإسرائيلي الذي فهمه
أنه يمكن أن يمنحه ميزة هو مجرد رأيي الشخصي
رأيي الشخصي هو أنه يجب عليك إحضاره بأي ثمن
رهائننا يعودون إلى منازلهم حتى لو كان ذلك يعني الجميع
للجميع، نعم، أعتقد أن هذا هو واجبهم
دولة إسرائيل لمواطنيها
الجنود
لها